le genre est l'un des grands sujets de
l'heure en janvier 2017 le magazine
national geographic consacré sa une à la
question du genre est allé à la
rencontre d'enfants un peu partout dans
le monde qui ne se définissent pas selon
le sexe avec lequel ils sont nés
transsexuels quils nont binaire à genre
androgyne fluide et variable ce ne sont
là que quelques-uns les qualificatifs
auquel s'identifie certaines personnes
en 2015
le magazine en ligne fut jeunes dévoilé
les résultats d'un grand sondage
effectué auprès d'un millier de jeunes
entre 18 et 34 ans la moitié des
répondants affirmaient que selon eux le
genre est un spectre et que certaines
personnes se trouvent à l'extérieur des
catégories conventionnel cette nouvelle
vision de l'identité soulève les
passions
par exemple à la suite de la publication
de l'article du national geographic
des dizaines de milliers de personnes
ont fait part de leurs réactions allant
de la fierté à la colère la plus totale